[Música]
ah
bueno bueno bueno bueno bueno como se ha
puesto para qué
así es que al final salió creíamos que
nos iba a acabar este veranillo verdad
qué barbaridad
con nada aquí estamos que pasa
porque rey
a que está lloviendo
bueno pues no sé qué podemos hablar hoy
venga vamos a hablar del tiempo me
parece bien ese tema de conversación tan
recurrente en ascensores en la panadería
en cualquier sitio cuando no sabemos de
qué hablar de qué hablamos de tiempo
verdad y es que cuando nos asomamos por
la ventana y vemos que el día está
lluvioso que sentimos
vamos a hacer un rápido sondeo de
acuerdo tenemos tres opciones tenéis que
elegir una de ellas luego pregunto al
final primero
sea vaya día me ve me quedo sin
salir hoy segunda me encanta el tiempo
lluvioso es una oportunidad es la
tercera ni siquiera me asomo a mirar por
la ventana a ver qué tiempo hace
normalmente como mucho lo miro en el
teléfono verdad vamos a hacer ese sondeo
rápidamente quién sería
por favor levantar la mano
y la vez
efe
claro y es que realmente la metrología y
esa percepción es completamente
subjetiva y esa subjetividad es la que
nos hace
por ejemplo pensar de manera diferente
ante el invierno pasado quién recuerda
este invierno que hemos tenido este año
dije
en casa vamos anotando los días de
nevadas
edwin 20 días de nevadas este año no es
un récord hay quien las podría notar con
pesadumbre o con alegría probablemente
no todos vivimos
esas nevadas de la misma manera y
seguramente a hubo gente que el gran
problema de las nevadas de este invierno
fue una gran oportunidad que el lujo
poder esquiar a los pies del producto
aquí en segovia bien sabéis que
presumimos de la rebequita las noches de
verano
bueno presumimos de eso pero en cuanto
caen cuatro gotas enseguida nos metemos
debajo de un porche sacamos los paraguas
o lo que es peor
suspendemos los recreos cuatro gotas
chicos y pipí
a clase que está lloviendo
y esto ocurre en este sitio como en
otros tantos en los cuales en verano los
embalses se vacían
como puede ser que personas que en
verano tengan problemas para poder tener
agua suficiente en invierno se quejen de
la lluvia y es que utilizamos la palabra
mal tiempo reflejando esa idea social de
lo que es bueno y es malo y consideramos
mal a la lluvia oa la nieve
hemos estado estudiando este fenómeno y
hemos acuñado un término que se llama la
aversión al mal tiempo sabéis lo que es
una versión una fobia es la manía
injustificada ante cualquier cosa ante
una cosa determinada
bueno pues esta aversión al mal tiempo
que nos parecía curiosa viviendo donde
vivimos hemos estado rascando un poquito
para ver en qué consiste y en primer
lugar tiene un componente que está
relacionado con el concepto de aversión
al riesgo aversión al riesgo es un
término que tim hill incorporó en las
actividades al aire libre tanto a las
actividades educativas como las
recreativas para explicar utilizando
este término que es del ámbito
financiero como los adultos nos
preocupamos en exceso por nuestros
menores así tenemos las casas blindadas
nos preocupamos mucho verdad el segundo
término es la bio fobia
ese término que también seguramente
suene y que es esa manía que le tenemos
a todo lo natural
vamos a analizar un poquito cual es cada
uno de estos dos aspectos para que le
tengamos manía al mal tiempo
por un lado la aversión al riesgo es esa
ese afán que tenemos por cuidar no por
blindar especialmente a nuestros menores
la sicóloga mari ángeles molina decía
que la sobreprotección es la jaula del
amor y una jaula no deja volar no deja
aprenderlo deja tener experiencias por
otro lado tenemos la bio fobia esa manía
a los insectos a la lluvia a la
incomodidad del frío al barro en los
zapatos
woody allen era un claro ejemplo de él
cuando explicaba que él y la naturaleza
eran dos
qué relación tiene esto con la aversión
al mal tiempo pues por un lado porque
tenemos aversión al riesgo de haber
aversión al riesgo a enfermar aversión
al riesgo a caminar un día de nieve y
caerse de culo
y porque tenemos bio fobia bio fobia que
yo fobia a la incomodidad de los charcos
al barro al frío a la humedad
claro naturaleza es así
y todo esto en un país en el que uno de
los principales problemas dejando de
lado los másteres
es la sequía cómo es posible que le
tengamos miedo y llamemos mal tiempo a
la lluvia
bueno pues como españolito que soy nos
vamos con mi familia de viaje a un sitio
donde no pasemos tanto calor en verano y
nos escapamos algo en agosto a un país
paradigmático irlanda y recorremos el
sudoeste de irlanda con nuestras
bicicletas para disfrutar de ese buen
tiempo
y un buen amigo me recomendó que leyera
el libro de javier reverte canta irlanda
seguro que algunos lo habrán leído y en
él encontré esta frase
que decía bolt en su diario irlandés
decía que es tan impropio llamar mal
tiempo a la lluvia irlandesa que decir
que un día de calor abrasador es buen
tiempo
estamos de acuerdo más o menos no pero
hay que vivir una cosa y la otra verdad
por tanto todo depende de nuestra
experiencia en ese mismo viaje mientras
íbamos en bicicleta encontré este
letrero nos acercábamos con ganas
después de pedalear bastante a una
heladería en una granja y recorremos la
isla de valència ahí en el wild atlantic
way lejos
apartado verdad y me encuentro este
letrero que dice que disponen de una
área interior y cubierta para jugar
y yo me pregunto y si en bicicleta
estuviéramos recorriendo la provincia de
valencia en vez de la isla de valència
y encontrará un letrero de esa heladería
pondría también que disponen de un lugar
a cubierto para salvarse del sol
y es que le tenemos manía a ciertas
cosas de la meteorología y no generar la
todo
en realidad la lluvia la nieve el viento
pero sobre todo la lluvia suele ser un
buen es una buena excusa para suspender
cualquier plan
bueno no todos los que tenéis perros
sabéis que no hay excusas y hay que
salir
y por qué no aprovechamos ahora mismo
que tenemos
indumentarias adecuadas para poder salir
un nuevo amigo mío gallego me dijo que
no hay mal tiempo sino que hay ropa
inadecuada
y es que también otro buen amigo este
más antiguo más viejo me dijo quién
tiene miedo
habiendo hospitales y yo digo quién
tiene miedo a salir lloviendo experiente
una lluvia de agua calentita en la ducha
hay esperanza o no ya veremos a ver por
ejemplo qué es lo que vemos aquí en esta
imagen me podéis decir que veis
es un parque hay nieve verdad os digo
cuando está esta foto está la foto está
hecha a las dos y media de la tarde
después de un día soleado y esa misma
noche había nevado los rastreadores
sabéis muy bien lo que se puede ver es
más me podéis decir lo que no veis
huellas niños ya no porque se habían
marchado huellas porque los niños ese
día de sol
no jugaron en el parque
por protegerles
por comodidad nuestra de profesores o
por miedo a los padres a que luego no
nos caiga una regañina porque habían
llegado a casa calados
es una faena derivarles de esto
ahora mismo les podemos buscar una
indumentaria perfecta para poder
disfrutar de la nieve por ejemplo de la
lluvia
quien de pequeño no ha tenido las ganas
de pisar un charco
y ahora tenemos la suerte de disponer de
unas botas abrigadas porque os acordáis
de las katiuskas nuestras de antaño que
eran frías como bueno bueno pues ahora
vienen como repito bien aisladas esos
pantalones que se ciñen perfectamente
dejémosle que pise en los charcos que
aproveche en el mal tiempo
afortunadamente
esta imagen que tenemos aquí
puede cambiar este es el típico perchero
a la entrada de cualquier escuela verdad
con los babies y las zapatillas allí
colgadas y porque no lo podemos
transformar en invierno por este otro
perfectamente por qué no
afortunadamente como digo las cosas
están cambiando y por ejemplo proyectos
como el bosque escuela tienen a los
niños durante todos los días de la
semana durante todo el curso aprendiendo
y disfrutando al aire libre y me diréis
claro serán niños mayores no son niños
de educación infantil y diréis bueno
claro aquí en españa
pues no porque las miles de escuelas en
las que se ha inspirado los bosque
escuela que están ahora funcionando aquí
en españa vienen del norte vienen de
países como alemania como los países
nórdicos como escocia me podéis decir
que ellos no son expertos en mal tiempo
aquí tenemos una gran oportunidad porque
disponemos de un privilegio una
metodología extraordinaria y cuando esa
metodología cambia sigue siendo
extraordinaria
solamente hay que estar preparado no
sólo los niños sino sobre todo los
adultos porque si sabéis que el niño
tiene tanto frío como frío tiene el
padre o la madre
así que hay que ir bien preparados para
que estemos dispuestos a salir con los
niños fuera no hay una amiga y maestra
aquí cerca en un pueblo de las navillas
que ha decretado los viernes al campo al
principio con ciertas reticencias de los
padres ahora los padres están encantados
los niños que os voy a contar y durante
todos los viernes de todo el curso sale
al campo con ellos y diréis bueno a
pasar el rato no a aprender también
porque en el campo se puede aprender
muchas cosas y sobre todo reconectar con
cosas que estábamos perdiendo
y es que sí no
esta aversión al mal tiempo tiene
ciertas consecuencias cuáles son esas
consecuencias por un lado y
consecuencias ecológicas diréis que el
cambio climático de no no de que nos
estamos desarraigando de la naturaleza
de ese entorno para el que estamos
diseñados durante miles de años ahora
nos tenemos que estar re adaptando a
espacios y entornos nuevos y si no me lo
podéis decir que gracias a que víctor
nos ha puesto de pies pues hemos estado
bastante más cómodos y tenemos que estar
aquí mucho tiempo sentados seguramente
que aquí alguno acaba cohecho en 4
verdad estamos hechos para estar en la
naturaleza por lo tanto la aversión al
mal tiempo nos desconecta de ese entorno
y de ese ecosistema para el que estamos
diseñados queramos o no y por otro lado
económicas no son menos importantes
porque al más mínimo síntoma de mal
tiempo es buena excusa para por ejemplo
cancelar la excursión que teníamos de
fin de curso
y más aún esa versión que tenemos al mal
tiempo nos hace tener las calefacciones
a tope en pleno invierno y tener el aire
acondicionado
hasta cifras gélidas en pleno de verano
y eso nos afecta
al bolsillo y es simplemente en una
cuestión completamente subjetiva
así que ya sabéis lo que dice la frase
célebre castellana verdad
todos a la vez al mal tiempo buena cara'
muchas gracias
y empieza a llevar
[Aplausos]
suave suave
[Música]
o no